nous l'aimons 5 en laye où si j'ai une
tante c'est super de couleur charles
avec ma mère espèce de fils de gens là
des deux mamans et tu vas être muji avis
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cette année encore l'émission danse avec
les stars devrait faire son retour pour
une 12e saison le programme lancé en
2011 sur tf1 s'essouffle autant en terme
d'audience que de casting c'est pas une
mauvaise performance même si c'est ce
qu'on pourrait penser la production
aurait donc décidé de casser la tirelire
en contactant la star des réseaux
sociaux nabil hargne et maintenant je
fais pas manger je suis riche mais selon
public ces conditions ils sont cachés ne
saurez pas si simple à négocier
l'affluence aux réclamerait un million
d'euros que les répétitions se passent à
son domicile à dubaï si elle vient c'est
pour sauver le programme qui sans elle
est mort déjà je sais pas si elle pourra
si on lui donne la raison de prendre
exactement à démarrer les exigences à un
million je pense qu à 800 milles ça peut
le faire il faut dire que 800 milles ce
serait une deux fois plus que par alan
bersin
elle ferait minimum trois semaines
qu'elle serait sûr ne pas être éliminés
et après peut-être ajouter mais je sais
pas son nom
c'est entre guillemets truqué c'est à
dire que les arriérés de faire trois
émissions mais comment ils peuvent
savoir si mabilat ils disent qu'ils
veulent assortir tout de suite mais il
faut gérer ce qu'ils veulent
je pense que la production ne peut pas
aligner un million d'euros le maximum
qu'ils aient fait ces quatre cent mille
euros un million c'est presque le prix
d'un prime donc c'est compliqué moi j'ai
eu thomas inhabile à cet après-midi ce
qu'ils disent est jetée marquée elle
veut un million a priori c'est plutôt la
production qui l'avait elle a même pas
eu de contact avec la production pour
l'instant accord et elle a priori elle
ne fera pas de mal cette année parce
qu'elle va accoucher prochainement et
préfère s'occuper de son arrivée donc si
elle le fait c'est pas pour cette année
c'est ce qu'ils disent
on connaissait clash entre booba et
carris qui a failli finir en octobre ou
en octobre de cette fois ci c'est dans
le monde de la télé réalité que ça
chauffe ça va finir sur un imac le mois
dernier dylan avait lancé un appel sur
son compte instagram pour trouver un
concurrent à sa hauteur pour organiser
un combat de boxe anglaise mon contact à
la fédération française de boxe m'a dit
que j'aurais pu faire un combat contre
un autre influenceurs juste dommage
qu'il n'y ait pas de candidat de télé
réalité à ma hauteur un appel auquel
influenceurs benjamin samata répondu
présent 10 26 rue je suis un homme bon
bein un petit dylan n'a pas tout de
suite pris cette réponse au sérieux les
deux hommes vont bel et bien s'affronter
sur un ring le 6 avril prochain au
palais des sports de marseille merci à
dylan et benjamin d'être avec nous dylan
tu mesure combien à m 86 oui comme un
îlot 74 et toi benjamins 1 m 70 et pour
combien de kg 72 72 c'est vrai que ces
investisseurs et alors où est ce que
vous vous entraînez vous vous entraînez
la forme qui m'avait menti jeu mêlant 10
km 80
moi ça fait longtemps que je voulais
faire des combats de boxe presse que
malgré tout ça reste du sport bien sûr
c'est une pièce des rations francesca
derrière c'est organisé il ya une
structure tout est carré que boxe
anglaise boxe anglaise vous vous
entraînez en ce moment ouais deux fois
par jour ou deux fois par jour quatorze
fois par semaine alors ça va ça commence
à apprendre ben ça va petit à petit il
ya un petit talon quoi un petit peu ah
ouais savoir pas garde à savoir la garde
c'est toi est à moi
bon il est pas mal c'est vrai ouais
laisser les cookies sont puissants
comment tu te sens très bien je suis
chez moi tous les deux mais pour moi
c'est une pitrerie et disant que c'était
moi j'aime que tu consultes tu
cautionnes pas la boxe mais tu
cautionnes quelqu'un qui te choque dans
une église n'ont déjà pas de logique tu
vois qu'aujourd'hui on utilise et autres
à notre influence pour faire du sport
sur tu vas conçu un mec qui turque dans
une église mais tu vas pas cautionner de
sportif qui monte sur un ring bravo ya
aucune logique dans ce que tu dis à
moulins sportive n'a aucune portée
c'est génial parce que ça sert
d'ascenseur social
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
deck est
là je n'avais pas peur de vous deux vous
abîmez visage non ça c'est le jour hing
c'est que non bah oui mais c'est quand
même aussi beaucoup joué sa plastique
chauffard risque aussi s'il ya pas de
plastique là dedans
est-ce que vous pouvez nous faire une
petite démo un pourvoi un petit peu ce
que ce que ça a donné les cours depuis
l'élu est-ce que momo tech et la monaque
made in coach vas-y à l'hormadi
[Musique]
et
benjamin dessus du but nous fait un
petit
nazis alors il ya une différence voir
que l'abus de taille c'est différent
c'est que amar j'avais jamais fait de
leçons avant le 9 mai
non mais je montre ce que je sais faire
mais j'ai commencé il ya deux semaines
d'accord ah oui ça va être court j'ai
coincé deux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je suis inquiet
j'ai aussi regardé mon mémoire je
connais un petit peu voilà voilà un
tailleur tard mois là il faut que tu
envoies
tous les influenceurs à dubaï vont se
faire virer sauf j'estime au made in m6
et stéphane et durante et son chéri
pendant et après ces informations
certains influenceurs pourraient être
expulsés dans les prochains jours car il
entretiendrait des relations avec des
gens peu fréquentables et n'aurait
aucune société à leur nom dans le pays
alors les stars de télé-réalité bientôt
prié de quitter dubaï croyez vous à la
rumeur
hugo ils deviennent des stars grâce à la
télé française ils gagnent de l'argent
grâce aux français qui les suivent sur
les réseaux sociaux et l'argent qu'ils
gagnent des sommes astronomiques on le
sait tous ils vont à dubaï pour ne pas
payer d'impôts à leur patrie et la
france qu'on aime et qu'on respecte moi
s'il dubaï dégagent les stars de télé
réalité ça ne pose aucun problème je
pense qu'ils auraient bien raison c'est
pas vrai déjà il y en a qui ont des
sociétés domiciliées en france ensuite
ma j'enquête effectivement vous pouvez
expulsés de dubaï si vous commettez
certaines fautes très graves un crime un
viol du trafic de stupéfiants vous êtes
automatiquement expulsé si on rayonne
voitures
qui sont ils sont très dur là dessus là
en l'occurrence ce sont des fausses
rumeurs basée sur le fait que ces
personnes génère énormément de jalousie
qu'elle gagne beaucoup d'argent et
qu'elles sont très critiquées notamment
par les français mais aucune de ces
personnalités n'est menacée d'expulsion
c'est basé aussi sur le fait qu' on a
certaines qui songent à partir et qu'ils
ont plus ou moins annoncée nabila veut
partir notamment dans trois quatre ans
aux états unis mais ça n'a rien à voir
avec sa danse est une fausse rumeur
basée sur l'âge l on voit là j'y crois
pas une seule seconde c'est tout
bénéfice pour l'image de 12 de dubaï
world motion c'est tout bénéfice et elle
vous rendez compte tout ce qu'ils font
comme comme buzz là dessus et tout ça
c'est qu'elle est en quoi c'est un
bénéfice pour dubaï au dubai battant
l'image qu'ils donnent malgré tout à
battants avec tous les suiveurs et tout
ça pourquoi je n'entends parler de dubaï
par les
fiches complètes conserver oui mais
justement s'il s'en fichent ils vont pas
les expulser non plus comme didier
guillaume ils ont pas tuer père et mère
donc je n'y crois pas un seul instant
c'est de la pub oui pour le moment aucun
influenceurs aucune influence us n'a
reçu de lettre mettant fin aux visas cd
vise à prolonger entre 1 et 3 ans aucun
n'est visé juste il y en a 2 dont on
peut pas donner les noms parce qu'il ya
une procédure judiciaire contre eux qui
eux risquent l'expulsion mais ça n'a
rien à voir avec une volonté de double
aïe de virer les influenceurs absolument
pas beaucoup moins d'argent en ce moment
on sait que les recettes il y avait 300
ou 400 mille euros par mois par mois on
est plutôt de diviser par quatre
ses com et salades de l'argent
c'est ça fait moins et puis c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui les nouveaux arrivés
quelques plus du tout de zai du tout
donc c'est plus sonné le radeau donc ça
va disparaître
un combat de boxe entre deux
influenceurs dylan thiery et benjamin
samat
et après un combat en trois bandes c'est
finalement benjamin qui a réussi à
s'imposer
et le moins qu'on puisse dire c'est que
l'équipe de tpb amiens unis caution ce
coup là j'ai des amis les papiers
jeunes habillés sur dylan ma couille
[Applaudissements]
benjamin pour l'instant il a un petit
peu de boulot belge
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
j'entends chercher le mot de tanis non
mais dylan qui s'est passé mon permis
j'aime bien benjamin aussi ouais et
qu'est ce t'as vu féraud il s'était très
bien entraîné et est vraiment très fort
un jeune un peu c'est estimer et 15
secondes après après le premier round je
me suis pété l'épaule c'est vrai à la
franche et directe moi je me suis battu
à la main droite et je suis pas non plus
mohamed ali pour pour le battre juste
avec une main j'étais content d'avoir
fait ça mais moi je suis très content
ouais ça reste du sport mais j'aurai ma
revanche et c'était aussi je me battrai
pas l'épaule vrai que draka revanche
bien sûr je tiens à gagner combien m
enfin parce que tu as un verset de
l'association
danse avoir été payée mais après je peux
dire qu'il ya eu 1500 places devant du
d'accord à combien il ya des places à 20
euros à 50 euros à 100 euros et hier des
tables jusqu'à 40000 euros
je sais pas vraiment qui est qu'hier
sensible il ya eu sa carte avec la table
[Rires]
il ya eu un petit peu moins de 5000
peppers view vendus d'accord les 47
c'est un succès ouais un gros succès one
cossue près ça que je me transforme pas
donc tu vas faire ta revanche je peux
quand même temps tu t'laisses aller
signer 10 juillet juillet ouais on se
refaire le cheval en juillet avec
plaisir ce tome le ramadan je termine de
me guérir et thomas font alors et donc
ouais donc tu es tu faisais drama donc
ouais bien sûr bien sûr ouais ça tu as
été pas trop fatigué j'ai eu le temps de
couper ouais j'avais besoin de couper ou
d'accord parce que c'est vrai que non
mais tu sais il n'y a pas des femmes qui
veulent faire ça d'influencé
silva que s'échauffer s'arrêta à pédales
turner
demain qu'est la vainqueur du combat
salut belgique
[Applaudissements]
bah
écoute bien des lilas son écharpe
franchement ça a été un outil et je sais
que j'y gagne il a le droit ça en
revanche à bravo que parce que bien sûr
il a porté ses
contrats nets chaîne tim spero sur le
ring de marseille est il en droit
d'avoir sa revanche surtout que c'était
vraiment un très très bel événement on a
kiffé eu comme moi non c'était beau de 8
mois puis bien évidemment pas bien sûr
mais mais mais franchement c'était
c'était trop bien trop bas excitant et
c'est l'une des premières fois depuis
des années des années qu'on réussit
rampling enquirer une salle en boxe
anglaise en france donc ça a été un
événement qui pour nous est en gros
mission accomplie merci
[Applaudissements]
prostitution officiellement interdite
aux émirats mais pourtant tout l'airé à
dubaï a fait de cette ville la
principale destination en matière de
tourisme sexuel dernière polémique en
date le porte à poti gate ou le scandale
des escort girls considérés comme des wc
ambulance sur la vidéo qui servent de
cette semaine on peut voir un homme
faisant kaka dans la bouche d'une femme
plusieurs blogueurs ont révélé sur leur
chaîne que certaines à fortis à daumeray
des pratiques scatophile pour assouvir
le fantasme de riches milliardaires tu
faisais escorte manger kaka de gros
monsieur
certaines d'entre elles pourrait
empocher jusqu'à 20000 euros pour subir
de telles humiliations physique en fait
tout a commencé à quatre mois c'est un
youtuber anglais qui a fait une vidéo en
disant que certaines jeunes femmes à
dubaï avait recours à ce genre de
pratiques pour illustrer la vidéo il a
mis des photos regarder de candidate
française en l'occurrence les jumelles
el himer mais aussi mis la jeunesse
mines suite à ça il ya un blogueur qui
s'appelle aquabaie qui s'est emparée de
la sphère qui enquête depuis longtemps
sur les rumeurs de prostitution dans la
télé réalité entre temps sur youtube
leur anglais a mis une autre vidéo un
commentaire pour dire que ces photos en
fait ils les avaient dû smith pour
illustrer le sujet et qui ne les
connaissais pas personnellement d'accord
là aujourd'hui c'est parole contre
parole les influenceurs en question
disent qu'elles vont attaquer toutes les
personnes sur les dénigrent parce
qu'elles sont victimes de harcèlement et
le blogueur aquarive dit lui qu'il a des
preuves concrètes et c'est ça qu'on
attend des preuves concrètes elles
étaient recrutés pour des soirées elles
ne savaient pas forcément que des
pratiques scabreuses ou délirantes
allait se produire elle arrivait dans
une chambre après avoir rendez vous avec
un milliardaire et elle se trouvait
souvent face à quatre hommes des gardes
du corps aient été forcés à des choses
et pour les forcer parfois elle était
droguée donc après il y avait
effectivement
défécation sur elle
forcer à manger leur vomi des rapports
sexuels avec des animaux non et le chant
et le chantage c'est le chantage c'était
drogue et ont confisqué les papiers ont
leur confisquer leurs papiers québec
nous en tant que candidate de télé on
reçoit souvent des propositions qui sont
assez avec des sommes assez
astronomiques ça c'est vrai ça nous à
jour pour l'heure on reçoit des trucs
toujours avec moi ça vous pourrez
envoyer des photos des photos de pied ou
pour eux de paix ouais et reçu des
diamants j'ai déjà reçu des propositions
jusqu'à 5000 euros pour une photo de
piste pour 5000 euros pour les jetons
que ça voudrait dire un quidam pour mon
pays dans la gueule
5000 euros pour défaut de pelé on va
dire demander des photos dénudées aussi
oui ça on reçoit tout le temps
effectivement délai courant vous dire
votre combien ça va arriver ça varie en
fonction du fief de la personne je
suppose j'aurais pris doivent être pas
méchant mais à dix mille dix mille rouge
ouais ça peut aller c'est normal et
jusqu'à 50 millions jusqu'à déjà des
copines à vous qui sont posés la
question qui sont différées que c'est
énormément d'argent
est-ce que je ne vais pas intéressé bien
de notre vie justement pour pas avoir à
se la poser cette question même si tu
vois quand même malgré tout et si jamais
la can alain lemay les matchs que tu
accompagnes quelqu'un pour cinquante six
mille euros la semaine je reconnais que
tu peux te dire quand angie coup alors
le mail on peut pas avoir le meilleur
temps là ici voilà et de metz et tu te
dis si tu es une jeune fille c'était
juste un coup gagné milliardaire dîner à
bercy
c'est en anglais elle allait les
montants sur la fin oupeye 1000 euros
par jour ouais c'est incroyable will
give you et au viol cinquante six mille
pour la semaine ouais ou pas cette et
ils disent quoi il dit c'est quoi pour
accompagner sa compagne de rendez-vous
burj al arab alors alors là oui c'est ça
oui mais qd aux réservations for you une
suite à wii c'est incroyable réseau ça
commence à être précis rendez vous dans
une suite vous avez un examen d'un
chauffeur ouais donc vous raconter un
chauffeur avec avec une luxueuse voiture
pour cinq ans et vous êtes payés 58 me
l'a dit sur l'histoire du passeport
c'est là que les filles doivent faire
attention parce que une fois que tu es
là bas les futurs en comparaison gilles
petit peu dit il peut il peut attester
ce que je dis il ya quinze ans des
footballeurs professionnels étaient au
début quand ils sont partis jouer à
dubaï pour l'argent les présidents de
clubs prenaient leur passeport et dites
vous bien qu'un mec un footballeur
professionnel un homme ils étaient
bloqués à dubaï il pouvait pas partir
mais footballeur renommée qui avait joué
en ligue 1 qui était connue ils étaient
bloqués là-bas ils pouvaient pas partir
même des mecs qu'on joue en équipe de
france donc faut dire aux filles faut
pas partir là bas comme sa tête baissée
en disant je vais aller prendre deux
cent mille euros en en un mois parce que
s'ils prennent le passeport c'est
terminé et est dans la merde
[Musique]
les monstres la cgt c'est super de
coulon charles avec ma mère espèce de
fils de de gier la d2 mamés et tu vas
être tomoji avis j'ai tout moggi
alors ce qu'elle a bien fait de diffuser
la wii
moi j'ai fait oui bien sûr daniel way à
moi je trouve évidemment appuyant ac
c'est hyper chaud quand il rentre il est
bête soit disant pour demandé de
l'amener il prend le sakhir pas c'est
traumatisant mais va pas dire est ce que
je peux te prendre
un peu comme aux antilles dhofar ouest
malheureusement non n'est pas dire oui
mais si quand on voit des actions comme
ça je suis dit c'est pas vrai que les
mêmes hamedani encore
je dis pas qu'il faut le protéger je dis
juste que ce qu'elle a fait est illégal
c'est donc tu ne
il a fait des choix déterminants
problème tu ne te ne lutte pas contre
quelques une action illégale on est en
toi même dans les
galas vidéo tu la donnes aux flics et
les figues ou vont chercher sur les
réseaux sociaux
excusez moi avec tout le respect que je
vous dois je ne suis pas du tout
d'accord avec vos propos donc j'assume
totalement ce que j'ai fait pour moi
c'est un acte de défense tout d'abord
pourquoi parce que déjà je me fais voler
dans un magasin on rentre on prends mon
sac on se barre je cours après j'arrive
pas est court plus vite que moi alors
que j'ai encore une la moitié de mes
extensions sur la tête j'ai vu l'autre
moitié l'autre moitié
ça fait vraiment de l'effet
c'est pas une super publicité
juste à faire un rappel à la loi alors
moi je vois c'est illégal aussi de voler
nos comptes et comment donc je sais il a
été la qualité alors qui va gagner ce
que je vous propose en fait c'est
simplement je comprends votre peine je
comprends votre chagrin vous avez
travaillé cependant je ne fais pas la
loi moi même je fais un acte de défense
et surtout je fais une enquête par moi
même je ne condamne jamais personne je
ne suis pas je ne suis même pas mal
fermée
moi vous êtes enquêtrice mahb autres
imitateurs quêteurs oui pas des gens je
publie vous savez qualifier quelqu'un
c'est trois ans de prison
il également c'est illégal c'est illégal
aussi de voler en sol humide
et commissariat les policiers ont trop
de travail pour s'occuper d'un petit
pays comme le mien ça les policiers boss
excusez moi non
je n'ai absolument pas ce grâce à cette
vidéo et ben j'ai eu peur j'ai eu
contact avec trois magasins trois
magasins qui ont la même description et
la même vidéo surveillance avec sa
cellule voilà voilà voilà et dire qu'il
a fait oui plusieurs fois et dans la
même semaine et dans le même quartier du
coup et ce qu'ils aient retrouvé alors
ce gars là n'ont toujours pas non mais
bon en tout cas ils sont sur la piste
toi oui mais ça serait bien gras sur la
piste
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]